bon les gars je peux commander un truc
ou quoi non je peux pas on discute là
votre nouvelle série inédite c'est quoi
de merde là le client ici il les ro tu
connais pas laise ou quoi pour moi un
mec qui répond les autres c'est pas un
bonhomme c'est un esclave elle a jamais
tapé de sa vie pas que tuoublie d'aller
acheter du chichon mon chaton et ça
c'est une tradition familiale que moi je
vais perpétuer je comprends rien toi
tuis pas qu'on commence à devenir des
vrais bonhommes là les gens ils sentent
çao et ça tu le sens la première
incursion des lascar dans l'univers
impitoyable du travail c'est pas triste
oh merde comme dirait
qu'orte sou tant qu'on pas de verrue
lascar tout travail mérite galère à
partir de vendredi 20h50 en exclusivité
sur Canal plus
série